[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we have an episode that we haven't
covered this topic yet which is super
interesting we're gonna be talking about
sociology we're going to be talking
about political science we're in talk
about political communication we'll be
talking about peering inside the
propaganda machine we have dr. Emma L
bright with us it's great to be here
appreciate ya it's fun to be here it is
super fun to have you as especially
because your visiting scholar right now
at Stanford yeah welcome to our Bay Area
enjoying it's a great place to spend the
summer yeah and you spend you live and
spend most of your time the United
Kingdom yes yes absolutely
my main role is as a senior lecturer and
in the journalism department at
University of Essex so I'm just over
here on my sabbatical doing some
research over here and how many years
have you been doing the senior lecturing
at SS actually only a year before that I
was a lecturer at University of
Sheffield yeah and Sheffield's also in
UK yep yep both in the UK in England
yeah
in journalism yes those were both
journalism departments although I'm a
sociologist and political scientist yes
yeah and there's a lot to unpack yeah
because we've had some insanity
regarding propaganda in the last couple
of years that would describe my whole
life I think propaganda yes that's
basically my main specialism is
critiquing and studying systems of
propaganda and the people responsible
for them yes and so maybe start us off
with the thesis and about the applet
propaganda of what you've been studying
sure and well yeah so I first sort of
stumbled into this as part of my
undergraduate studies at Coventry
University it just after 9/11 I was
doing my undergrad degree and one of the
final year modules I got to do was
called propaganda and foreign policy and
I thought oh how exciting is that this
sounds fascinating and I just kind of
fell in love with the general topic and
decided to do my PhD on that I mean we
we had covered sort of propaganda in all
sorts of historical context and I
decided actually you know what there's a
hell of a lot of that going on right now
in the world and I want to look at that
in the contemporary context so I decided
that my methodology for my PhD at
Glasgow University was going to be
interviewing propagandists and I thought
you know kind of naively like I can do
that that's fine that'll be easy I and I
do my first presentation that everybody
is like they're not gonna talk to you
you know yeah no one is gonna talk to
you so I was like I I wasn't gonna let
that get to me so what I did was I went
out to the states and I was there for
like about nine months the three top
role this is not me interviewing
scientists and entrepreneurs this is
yeah this is interviewing people that
purposely plug in manipulations into the
social and why are they going to reveal
to you what they do so my thesis was
basically about British and American
propaganda so the stuff that governments
do to communicate in the context of war
you know both abroad and also selling
water the people at home and I decided I
was going to study that by interviewing
those people who do the communicating
the propagandists themselves I I studied
I got interviews both in the UK and in
the US I actually went over and spent
nine months in America in Washington DC
meeting with people like CIA station
Chiefs people in the White House and
and people who had been out in
Afghanistan and Iraq and I got loads of
interviews as well with with contractors
who had been hired to sort of market war
and sell certain ideas to people in
Afghanistan for example and to also
justify the wars that were ongoing and
that was at a time when you had really
you know shocking things coming out in
the media as well about atrocities that
had been committed by military personnel
in Iraq and so on and by both countries
and it was a very difficult time when it
comes to attacks that were taking place
and how you respond to you know
terrorists and and try to counter
terrorism and stop it getting worse
those people were trying to recruit and
they were using atrocities to do that so
you're put in this very difficult
position I think as a country of how you
try to to address problems of there are
a real and existing in relation to
terrorism but also there was an effort
to sort of justify and legitimize
actions that had already been taken and
also try to obscure things that had
happened that were really really
questionable and wrong but gave the
country a lot of sort of bad PR so I was
really interested in all of that and
also the process of digitalization
because we were entering in Internet age
you know we had into the Minturn age the
military were kind of slow to catch up
on that and they were transforming the
field of propaganda and that was partly
why they were bringing in all these
contractors contractors like SCL group
who I interviewed as part of my studies
my PhD
ventually became a book called
propaganda and counterterrorism
strategies for global change and I
interviewed this some of these people
called from SCL group for that book as
well
these were contractors hired by British
and American militaries and and State
Department a sword for during
counterterrorism work and I later on
realized that they became involved in
politics as well now these this company
actually is the parent company of a
company you will have heard of Cambridge
analytical who have been across the news
in recent times but at that time nobody
had heard of them at that time when I
was interviewing them but because I
developed all these like strong links
and a relationship with the people in
the company through interviewing them
over a long time I knew more about the
what they were doing and I was able to
get access more easily when it came to
doing interviews later so my first
interest was really in defense security
propaganda how the state does its
propaganda and then also afterwards
after I'd finished that PhD I started
writing about refugees and how they're
represented in the media and I did a
second book called bad news for Refugees
which looks at their misrepresentation
yeah so I was always interested in that
as well yes okay so let's unpack there
so kind of you kind of in me you painted
a vision for me of of government using
propaganda to identify both malevolent
and intent in a different place in the
world to justify the war but also a sort
of domestic propagation of both that
image as well as maybe an image of not
only malevolence they're justified but
also sometimes a
something that makes people feel a
certain way about another group of
people like you were saying that if
research in your second and the second
thing that you wrote about Muslims and
another case was that you were
mentioning about just in general it's
just this notion that that manipulation
can occur for among government to
justify the way that they are behaving
across and you know counterterrorism
over such a long long period of time it
became you know in order to sort of
justify increasing spending on
counterterrorism these conflicts in Iraq
and Afghanistan and so forth you ended
up with you know very very negative
representations of Muslims in the media
because Muslims were being overly
reported as being responsible for
terrorism in comparison to positive
stories about Muslims they would always
be in the media as terrorists or
potential terrorists or you know because
we're we were fighting a war and this
was the way that the war was being
packaged and sold to us and so people
which is giving you this insight you're
intervening the propagandists and that's
what's kept us and then there's also the
digitization of propaganda which is no
longer just in newspapers but now it's
on the Internet in our newspaper and
that totally changed the landscape as
well because it was globalized and you
ended up with with a situation where for
example propaganda used to be targeted
at domestic audiences very differently a
to audiences abroad and that became a
difficult problem to manage when you
have the internet making it possible for
anything to go anywhere in a way so then
we ended up in this world of like having
to develop micro targeting to to
get specific audiences differently and
so on online and and that basically grew
out of a lot of the problems that we
were having when it came to domestic and
foreign targeting you end up with
enemies at home as well who the the
military might be not well not
specifically the military but the the
authorities might be targeting domestic
audiences as well and that creates all
sorts of problems because there are
rules over what you can target at home
and abroad and so forth so it gets very
complicated when it comes to how you
respond to domestic threats for example
so those those kinds of changing rules
and how how lines became blurred between
what was targeted at home and what was
targeted abroad are the sorts of things
that I got really interested in as well
as the sort of you know racism and how
that was being shaped as well
racist representations of Muslims and so
forth yeah so they're the propaganda
plays a certain way now in the digital
age where it can be easy to justify
going and making a military move into a
certain area due to there being bad
people there there being bad people at
home and needing to change migration
efforts or immigration efforts this is
something that part of your work is also
a migration yeah so okay so it seems to
be that the background was kind of
perfect for this a lot of interviewing
of of propagandists and learning more
about the way that were so this was this
is a a couple years ago is the like for
me yeah so so the book was published in
2015 on propaganda and that was just
after the one on on refugees I then
after that started sort of continue
working in this kind of area
but I got really interested in the
political context of why this is
happening how we can't you know maybe
direct more more of our money away from
from this military-industrial complex if
you like that so self-generating and
towards you know resolving problems like
economic inequality so one of the things
I was interested in is why the Democrats
can't communicate this topic of economic
inequality
oh stop that there's no money in peace
love and understanding will you stop
this nonsense okay I'm just kidding I
told you I was advocating I had to study
politics of America at a really
interesting time I came over here doing
a short spell at George Washington
University where I was doing some
research on the elections in 2016 and
2017 and it was all during this time
when economic inequality could not have
been more stark and the ways in which
different groups were being manipulated
in the u.s. became really really you
know clear to me and I realized halfway
through that time this group that I had
studied SCL group the parent company of
Cambridge analytic er the they had had
involvement in all of this the the
company that sprung up from them from
this defense contractor had begun
working for Trump and so I decided I was
going to try and get interviews with
them because I already had done a lot of
you know had a lot of connections and
and I managed to get in quite good easy
interviews and I also realized that they
had been working on brexit as well
because that was being reported by the
journalist Carol Cadwallader from The
Guardian she did some amazing reporting
on that
let's get a little bit of background
here okay so so let's talk there's a
billionaire his name's a Robert Mercer
yes and so Robert Mercer helped with a
lot of the Steve bannon's company that
was a complete box right Bart and then
and then Robert Mercer was also a funder
of SEO group yes
which okay for Cambridge analytic oh and
then why would now okay now you're
talking about Trump election which I
sure wanted to get Trump in yeah okay
and then there's the the Cambridge
analytical arm and the the brexit also
brexit in the 2016 election okay so
there's these two things that we're
gonna be talking about yeah now what why
would they want to take a meeting with a
journalist
why would someone I'm not a journalist
I'm an academic
an academic studying propaganda mm-hmm
like why are you already I had
interviewed them for my propaganda and
counterterrorism book well but if they
know that they have a vulnerability of
potentially having the 2016 influence
revealed or the brexit their influence
on though these two things are people
who don't feel wrong ripple oh they
didn't at the time they want to feel
like college very arrogant yeah they
they they are by definition people who
feel invulnerable they think that they
can't be shaken at all by anyone or
anything they think if they if they talk
to the media they expect to have you
know an article in on the front page of
The Times perhaps which might be
annoying but they don't expect it's
going to destroy their company they talk
to an academic they expect that those
people will publish their stuff in some
academic journal that will never ever
get read or in a book that will get read
by about 200 other academics and
normally that's the case my last book
did not make lots of money you know
people tend not to buy academic books
for their bedside table reading
No and so even these people wouldn't
normally even be destroyed by an article
in the media but like even less so by
academic work usually and that's that's
a shame and I think a lot more academics
need to be looking at the dark side of
the of propaganda there's a lot of
people who spend an awful lot of time
looking at how you know America can can
talk more positively about itself and
not looking beneath the surface of
what's going wrong with the systems of
power and that kind of research is very
very difficult to do it's difficult to
get people talking to you I do have a
lot of skill with interviewing and I
have known these people over a long
period of time built up a long long
amount of relationships if you like yeah
and have done critical work before but
it wasn't the sort of thing that they
were expecting was going to destroy them
in this kind of way now that company has
now gone bust
Cambridge analytical how would I do any
work anymore no they went bankrupt they
went bankrupt through the efforts of all
of the people who were revealing what
they did and what was the guy's name
Aleksandr Nix and then what was the
guy's name that whistle blows first Oh
Chris Wiley would Chris okay yeah Chris
Wiley so other than that process caused
game gentlemen a critical thing yeah the
whole all of these revelations all these
madly some of the companies are still
but I see all groups not bankrupt SEL
groups some of it went bankrupt SEL
insights are still going I believe and
there are other companies that have
sprung up from the ashes now this is
something that's not going to stop it's
only going to know going career is one
of those and they and their work
for Trump in 2020 so Kato date
appropriate date appropriate is that a
Mercer funded organization date
appropriate yes yes that's gonna get
even worse with artificial intelligence
and we can't even distinguish between
what is if you're watching this video
right now sure you see me but we can
synthesize my voice and synthesize my
face deep dr. Roman Young Polsky on our
show before and he okay is a deep
researcher and it's already happening to
deep fade alright this is already
happening it's getting scarier with each
each day it's really bad yeah so you
can't tell if if the video that you're
watching this Donald Trump's is gonna
send a tweet after you watch a video
about him saying something and just say
hey that wasn't me that was a deep faith
yeah I never thought about that exactly
so then so then the whole process of
whoever then he almost doesn't need to
do that anyway because nobody seems to
care anyway when he's nice which this is
this is very Orwellian what we're
speaking about because you can't tell
what reality is anymore from you know
today he was at the rally in West
Virginia and apparently everybody was
chanting lock her up and you know about
Clinton you know at this rally at a time
when he you know his campaign manager
and so on you know manna fort and and
Cohen as well as in court and there you
know I think manna fort got I think
convicted on eight of eight
what was it does anybody know the exact
I don't want to move to say it well you
don't know metaphor the news today and
Cohen was just indicted wasn't yet or
Cohen was indicted but there was also a
ruling on mana Ford I think he got
anyway it doesn't matter so is is that
is the issue that this seems to be a
little fascist that that the leadership
is just canceling out any voices or
opposition that is trying to go against
but the leadership believes in yes well
what since sorry you've lost me that you
jumped into something else I would just
just do that at any point if it seems to
be anyone is countering the perspective
of the leadership that they get locked
up or does that seem to be the worry
well I think one of the worries is that
they'll part I think Trump's they're
wondering if Trump will pardon these
people once they're convicted I think
that was one of the things that they
were worried about it but I have the
skinny on mana Ford he was found guilty
of five tax fraud charges one charge of
hiding foreign bank accounts and two
counts of bank fraud he faces a maximum
of 80 years in prison yeah so I think
what they're worried what Trump will be
worrying about is whether these people
have squealed and how much they squealed
wait so that metaphor and was his
campaign manager so he's now been
convicted of fraud and obviously there's
a big FBI investigation ongoing it so
then the question is is this real or not
well yes and obviously Trump would cry
fake news which helps you know hopefully
that's why eventually the West Virginia
rally because all of his fans were just
chanting lock her up and it's highly
ironic considering his campaign manager
around and his lawyer and right-hand man
is in court at the moment on on federal
charges you know this is really really
important and nobody who supports him
either cares or or even perhaps knows
because they're all watching Breitbart
or or Fox News perhaps or something and
it's a very different version of reality
that's being played to them I'm also
just although that it could very well be
that this is a extremely serious and
correct charge that's being applied at
the same time
it could be a smear campaign is that
correct for him for chock-full trumped
amana for what's happening could be a
smear campaign I doubt that somehow I
doubt that
as you said we don't know the answer
right well metaphor it's been convicted
so I think the court agreed that it
wasn't a smear campaign and I don't want
to question the judge and jury are you
gonna look on your face whenever you
play that advocate that that look on
your face is always the same I know I
know nothing but I'm skeptical of
everything but the jury is the one that
knows the evidence in the case of
spotting it to degree that I know zero
percent about so I'm just skeptical but
if the decisions made I wouldn't need to
spend months researching the information
to understand anything yeah so yeah so
of course I don't know [ __ ] yeah so
anyway yes so where I'm packing the 2016
election we're unpacking current 2018
news we're unpacking Breck's as well
this book on the Democrats actually and
it was called what's wrong with the
Democrats media bias inequality and the
rise of Donald Trump and I was doing a
lot of these interviews with Cambridge
analytic afore that actually and as I
was doing the interviews I started to
realize the kinds of things that I was
getting were really really important and
contradicted a lot of the claims that
were being made publicly and even in
Parliament about but in in the testimony
that Cambridge analytical were giving of
in relation to the elections in the US
and also in relation to brexit so I
started to realize that this was really
important stuff and that they were
telling me things that that they were
not telling other people and the reason
why oh yeah sure yeah well firstly I
should say before before you play that
yeah that the fake news inquiry
compelled me to submit all the evidence
they had in relation to them so I had to
give a give them all of my interviews
with with the different people from from
Cambridge analytic SEO as well as the
brexit campaign and they published some
of that as low as well as three
contextualizing explanatory essays that
I did that I'd written the other one the
yeah so so it's really important to say
that because because they they actually
published a series of audio clips and
you're just about to hear one of the
audio clips this is Nigel Oaks who was
the CEO of SCL group now that's the
defense contractor I taught the things
that resume and and they were the parent
company of Cambridge analytic ah so what
you're going to hear is him commenting
on the kind of strategies this is a clip
from the interview I did with him and
how do you score an interview at this
seat school are oh you get in well I had
I knew him before this I'd interviewed
him already and I just wrote him another
email saying I'm really interested in
interviewing you that was an academic
studying prop again I'm trying to learn
more I'm trying to write a book about it
I told him about the book and you want
and the person thinks that they're that
they're immortal and that they're able
to disclose how they're making
propaganda in a way that will be looked
at by some academics and that's not
going to harm them in the long term on a
mainstream media outlet yeah exactly and
he I mean I was interested in
interviewing with him about a number of
different topics so I was also
researching the military use of
propaganda as well and work that he was
doing in that regard so I interviewed
him over a number of different topics
and he was very happy to talk
to be military will fund propaganda that
okay's them to make military moves in
other well areas of the world or they
were doing counterterrorism and they
were doing targeting sort of what they
called target audience analysis so that
is research which helps them to
understand an audience that they're
hoping to target with propaganda and
they do sort of personality testing
gather intelligence analyze it and
develop messaging based on all of that
so that's the kind of work that they
were doing it's a military funded
psychometric profile and then once they
do the psychometric profile analysis
then they push propaganda towards that
direction yeah essentially that makes
what military decision well it depends
on the purpose of what they and us yes
they were working also for NATO and
doing training in in Eastern Europe as
well for countering Russia they would
they worked on this topic quite
extensively there's a lifetime pact
knowing zero percent about it absolutely
absolutely
this particular clip what you're about
to hear is him talking about what
Cambridge analytical were doing for
Trump and explaining the kind of
messaging that was involved this is 2016
know this well he's talking about the
the election in 2016 but this was
actually an interview in late 2017 late
2017 October okay it's about a year ago
yeah okay it's a things that resonate
sometimes to attack the other group and
know that you're going to lose them is
going to reinforce and resonate your
which is why you know Hitler very
careful but say never pumps say this off
the record but of course Hitler attack
the Jews because he didn't have a
problem with the Jews at all but the
people didn't write the Jews so if the
people yeah he could just use them to
say so he just leveraged an artificial
enemy well this is exactly what Trump
did he leveraged it Muslim you have
bigger threat is Isis really to America
yeah really and they were still talking
about 9/11 things that resident
sometimes detect to it what I find quite
sickening actually is the fact that this
guy built his entire career after back
of counterterrorism and the company has
expanded off off the back of that that
was the original company this was an
election that was very much focused
around you know the threat of
you know migrants of terrorists and so
forth and he makes it very clear that he
doesn't see this as a genuine threat and
and that he sees it as an artificial
enemy Muslims are being created into an
artificial enemy this is a company that
you know use this as a cynical tool and
they knew exactly what they were doing
in other ring and marginalizing a whole
whole religious group in a way that they
are comparing to what the Nazis did okay
let's unpack Ron quick question are we
at forty five right now oh okay great so
that's what I thought
awesome so okay let's unpack that clip
because in the clip it is said that
there was an artificial enemy as the
Jews and that that's an Hillard into
actually
and hatred yes he's kind of he's I was
shockingly anti-semitic I nearly fell
over when I heard this and I know you
probably heard it said off the record
this was I gave my entire interviews to
Parliament and they've chosen to publish
certain things that they felt were
extremely important for the public to
hear and this particular clip I think
really conveys the you know the ideology
behind the you know these people you
know their motivations their ideas which
were really fundamental to shaping the
type of approach I mean it's important
context where people needed to hear so
Robert Mercer funds
Nigel Oakes's a CEO group which he
speaks no sel group was actually funded
by conservative British funders called
the gaps a hundred percent funded by
thanks he was a large amount funded -
British conservatives group yes they are
they've all people who have funded the
British Conservative Party and yes so
they were British funders I think they
have a and in the SEO company was then
hired by Mercer - no no SCL group wasn't
they what happened was in about
2012-2013
they began setting up an American
company that was part of the group okay
so they it's a sort of a an offshoot of
the company which was able to do work in
American politics because you know they
were setting it up as an American
company British company isn't allowed to
run an American campaign so they set
this up as kind of a a like a front or
you know some sort of organization that
would be able to to run those campaigns
for them and
that was funded by the Mercer's so the
US subsidiary was yes exactly
oh okay now this is now mixing and that
is a part of the overall group okay yeah
yeah okay so then the subsidiary in the
United States is actually able to do the
manipulandum in the United States is
funded by the Mercer's yeah but they
were all drawing on a common core of
methodological suppose in research so
when you're in your conversation with
Nigel Oakes he then goes on to say that
how big of a threat do you actually
think Isis is how big of a threat do you
actually think yeah and he tells me as
well that you know he basically knows
that they that that the violence in
America isn't coming from Muslims and he
he talks it's coming from white
supremacists basically he he talks
there's another clip but Sir we won't
probably play that but he talks about
how it's actually you know not Muslims
that are causing the threat it's um you
know essentially white Americans who
let's let's change the language because
I think we have a lot of friends that
are Muslims that are fantastic people
and Islam in itself has a long history
of art culture music food grace
yeah and beauty so let's change the
language to Isis or to radical Islam or
the point because he's saying I think
it's really yeah I know I think I know
where you're going with this but I think
it's really important to identify that
nuance as something that is a precise
thing that we are talking about in this
conversation because if we do that then
it keeps everyone at home understanding
that we're talking about a specific
nuance so I just want them now this is
why I'm bringing this up this specific
nuance of radical Islamic terrorism like
Isis that's going on in the world is a
major problem of course it's a huge
global issue and it's happening in
Europe and it's half
in the United States yeah well you know
let's see what you happens to you when
people start bombing your country and
just pointing your finger just because
of what you practice if you look at the
statistics the amount of it's it's not
it's not quite as easy either
Ron it's that that's I think that's a
huge oversimplification of what's going
on there's a long history of
interpretations of specific aspects of
the Quran and the religious texts of
Islam that indicate the okayness of
genetic of genital mutilation of killing
people that leave the religion apostates
that this is a major bug in the code of
of that of that religion and and people
like sam harris are walking out on the
middle of a tightrope out into the
middle of the political scene saying
things like this is absolutely not okay
that this is still happening in the
world and even machine Nawaz someone
that is a former Muslim that still is
Muslim but that has came out and said
that I do not support those ideologies I
am not with them and there's tons of
people ayaan Hirsi Ali that are saying
this works both ways on all religions
the good in the bad the ugly of Monarch
okay we're not okay so let's let's again
let's make this really really really
clear I'm going to be very careful with
how I choose my words this has nothing
to do with the good in Islam and Muslims
those are amazing people and amazing
aspects of culture and life and
everything there but there is a Isis
there is no such thing as Isis for
Christianity or Judaism or Buddhism or
Hinduism there is no such thing as that
have been yeah yeah KKK is a perfect
example of Christianity doesn't exist or
gonna say
anyway white supremacists are causing
more political violence in the US than
Muslims are and I think that was the
point that Nigel Oakes was making in the
interview that I did with him and I
think it's a really important very
subjective evidence is that US Supreme
ISM that nationalistic people that white
supremist
white supremist are causing more deaths
and injuries in the United States than
radical Islamic terrorists okay okay
that's the government I will help into
that understand that but let's hold that
that was the United States let's talk
about the world because white
nationalists in the world are not
causing more deaths than isolate talking
right now about the United but now we've
created a separation between those two
things and okay wasn't we talking about
that I was talking about in the United
States I mean this was a conversation
about the United States he is talking
about the United States when people are
reading and really passed overseas if
and then committing crimes overseas like
killing people that we look at other
parts of the world there are horrific oh
you know ongoing problems in places like
Afghanistan Iraq that have not been
resolved by conflicts that are
supposedly over there is awful violence
that is afflicting these regions and
this is an ongoing problem that we have
not helped by the way it is causing
migration flows that is a problem though
there are awful situations of of
extremism and not just extremism but
violence and I'm not saying that those
things don't exist what I am saying is
that the greater problem in the United
States right now is a piece of white
supremacist [ __ ] so now that we've
packaged this into a very nuanced State
we've identified eight areas around the
world are have a serious issue with
radical Islamic terrorism
the United States on the other hand has
a bigger problem with white supremacy
that's how we've identified yes okay I
need to learn more about the white
supremacy okay good history book
yeah that's not actually what I'm you
know it took about really today I was
talking about my research which isn't
specifically on white nationalism I mean
if you should get someone who's a
specialist on white nationalism if you
want to go into that specific thing in a
greater way what I'm focused on with my
researches is propaganda
so what we're I would like to go if you
don't mind is to back to my research if
that's okay because I'm not only
important identify what we identified
yeah oh yeah absolutely it's important
context yeah yeah jump back in okay sure
so uh especially because that audio clip
in itself the reason why we just went on
that ten minute conversation was because
in that audio clip it has made clear
that who Nigel Oaks is referencing Nigel
Oaks is saying that Muslims are not the
problem in the United States
that's what he said and again let's he
said the word Muslims oh but then he
also said Isis but I think he said both
right is that true no um okay so well if
you wanted to we could play the clip
again and because I don't want to
paraphrase him and get you know because
you know but I think the most important
thing that we can take away from that is
actually that they know that that
Muslims are not the biggest threat in
America and that they were created well
all communications were created through
that campaign to make them into an
artificial enemy that's what he said
reference just like with Hitler energies
to other that and I think that's a
really important point and that that
process is not just something that
happened in the US as well if we look at
the campaign
happened in the UK previous to the u.s.
elections through brexit in the
referendum to leave the EU that was a
campaign leave dot EU campaign maybe you
could bring the picture up again now the
other one that the previous one that you
had before that yes so here you can see
the people associated with the leave dot
EU campaign so Nigel Faraj he was really
the figurehead of that campaign you've
got Erin Bates who funded lot leave dot
EU you've got Andy Wigmore who was their
communication director oh this is a
question I asked you beforehand it yeah
what's wrong with brexit Britain leaving
the European Union personally I voted to
remain and the reasons I voted to remain
were because I think we have very
complex transnational problems today in
our world that includes things like
terrorism it includes things like fake
news now more than ever it also includes
migration and climate change and from
climate change we're going to get more
and more migration we are entering into
a period of our future where we are
going to have to work together more than
ever before and I think that
transnational relationships and
political structures that are
International and cooperative are deeply
important to resolving those kinds of
problems we need to work together and
not be trying to float off into the
Atlantic Ocean on our own at the moment
we are not the world superpower that we
like to think we sometimes are and I
think it's really important to actually
work with the rest of Europe to come up
with cooperative strategies to manage
numbers of migrants and how
respond to different problems so that's
why I chose to vote that way personally
I felt I tend to agree with you in terms
of the long term yeah that there is
going to be some sort of a major push
across the world to figure out how to
work together in the long term how we
get there though is a very deeply
complicated they want sort of variable
equation that nobody really has the
answer to but it's things like the UK
leaving we're not we're gonna be another
lost civilization this planet is
littered with them and just we're next
we've especially with deep fakes and AI
and biotech explosion and malevolent
ways we never know what could happen so
we really have to talk about the ethics
and the morality and working together
and however we get there in the short
term is going to be an effort of a lot
of people trying to work together to
figure these these things out for
violence we'll get there through
violence of course ah that hopefully
hopefully we can get there with less
violence I'd be fantastic I think yells
never take me alive yes well um so I I
was also appalled by the the very racist
nature of the campaign it was very
anti-immigration and I think personally
that migrants aren't the biggest problem
in the UK um they are not even close to
it i I think these people are a greater
problem than UK personally but some
people that wanted it at least the elite
who are keen to profit after active
groups marginalized groups and turning
people against each other creating you
label the six people in here as people
that are thriving divisions in our
country driving divisions for profit and
marginalizing people in control control
to maintain control they'd rather have
us fighting amongst ourselves and they
can scheme to
just maintain control so I found the
tone of the entire campaign pretty
off-putting an appalling I honestly felt
quite dismayed at the brexit vote
however the the outcome of the vote was
was not the issue for me I have
continued to yeah I felt concerned about
both the propaganda but also about the
the illegality and the rule breaking of
electoral laws I'm able to make
propaganda for a political election no
but it's the kind of propaganda I think
okay so it's a problem ethically immoral
but it's not elite and the breaking of
no but there were laws broken and that
is what bothers which laws were broken
so for instance they were campaign
contributions and so forth that broke
the broke the rules they had to they put
too much money into the campaign can we
just go back to that image really quick
breaking points that was showed up
see here's here's my here's my one thing
if we can take away one thing from my
skepticism oh it's just that I believe
that there are good people in here I
also believe that there are some bad
apples in here and if I kill these
people you don't even know who they are
I can't you're absolutely right that's
exactly my point
if you don't know who the people are and
you've opened up your borders and you're
having a flood of people that you don't
know and haven't done any background
checks on entering your country you have
that in some case that is not actually
the case though one I'm wait wait Howard
wait how is that not the case with
people coming in on boats across the
Mediterranean people are not arriving in
Britain on boats they are arriving in it
look this is Britain okay this is a
different country fair enough they are
arriving in a sexual situation then no
and this
you know been choreographed very
carefully with a picture I don't know
where that picture came from but the
dudes give an impression that these
people are arriving in the UK and that
the UK is in breaking point
okay this basically this could be an
image of a thousand white people were a
thousand but it's honest and it's a
racist they could be any color would
still not know is the point yeah
but they are making an inference with
the fact that these are not white faces
okay and they are sure if this could be
a thousand white people and this could
be the president of Japan going hey we
can't let a thousand white refugees into
our country the point can be made across
any sort of color suits this minute I
wouldn't let a bunch of white refugees
into my country that's for sure they can
go back to where they came from
so it's an individual by individual
basis that's what is it significant that
you know immediately afterwards they one
of our politicians called Joe Cox who
was an advocate for refugees was stabbed
to death by a written first supporter
Britain first is one of the far-right
groups in the UK he stabbed someone to
death
yes damn a terrorist yes so we had a
terrorist incident in the middle of all
of this and I think it draws important
parallels to what happened also in the
in the states with Charlottesville and
there are consequences of these kinds of
narratives I would say that they charge
and they politically charged the
population and they are creating how
truthful are they is a big crowd
did you see the right do the white
missionary that's making the news in
Uganda at the hotel slapping around
Ugandan hotel receptionist in the name
of Jesus Christ he's a missionary doing
work out there and he slept around these
black people called racial slurs and
he's literally throwing punches it's
it's um it's disturbing the whole part
fact that this you know that is not
people arriving in the UK that's an
artificial enemy they're creating and
they are creating hatred against people
who are in the UK who you know are
suffering from you know there was a
massive spike in violence and hate
crimes right after they spoke and around
this book oh damn it's it's been
horrifying and you know this kind of
rhetoric does drive up violence you
can't measure against these you know
yeah and the so maybe we want to play
that next clip so this is the
communication director of leave EU and
these people talked about and to make
Wigmore yes the one in the middle middle
and this is on an augury not
inauguration day the day that Donald
Trump won the election they were all
partying together they leave dot-eu
campaign crew as well with with Donald
Trump the propaganda machine news of you
know the Nazis president if you take
away all that hideous horror yeah it was
very clever the way they managed to do
what they did
you know in its pure marketing say okay
you can see the logic absolutely they
were saying why they were saying and
presenting things and the imagery
everything from them okay and that is
propaganda oceans interesting steps or
whatever it is yeah well you know this
yeah but I know looking at that in
hindsight now becoming being and the
sharp end of this campaign ease right
now there's suddenly this is not new no
and it's just it's using the tools that
you have at the time
I think 2016 is unique I don't know you
could ever repeat it and I don't that
you could have a routine repeat the
technique yeah that people hadn't used
in 2016 is off its time really and
Twitter and Facebook of its time so this
is the guy that I interviewed and II
Wigmore what was the pull the main pull
for you from that clip I I think it was
the fact that it came out of nowhere for
me I wasn't asking either of these
people about Nazis or Hitler I was
asking them about 2016 and what went on
with the the EU referendum and they this
is what spontaneously came out of them
was justifications of the Nazis
this guy is basically saying how clever
the Nazis were their propaganda he it's
something he admires you know and Nigel
Oaks
similarly was talking about that
strategy in an in a glowing way now I
think that says everything about who
these people are that are reshaping
politics right now these are really
significant figures and they have put
huge amounts of money into influencing
our media and spreading hatred hateful
narratives around both in the US and in
the UK and also through you know
Breitbart and so forth all these
different right-wing media sources that
are spreading out across Europe as well
it's not just in in the US
I hate fluorescing
Pop's and drop ceilings you know when
they used to have got high ceilings and
then they put drop ceilings I hate that
handling to wood paneling over nice
plastered walls I would kiss me for so
good right now because it's such a
didn't sobbing such an insane topic I
know yeah I'm still gonna kick your ass
at the end of this for your ignorance I
might need another glass of wine
yeah go ahead Garcon please boy my grey
most him to blame Cofer bringing me back
to San Francisco for sure okay thank you
okay so so so now just don't just uh you
know let's see if we can include a
little bit of what the medium was that's
used for this it I really just want to
completely push all my marbles into like
the globalism table and until everybody
loved everyone table into the stop and
stop with a separation table and and
then you know as you stopped the
separation between people and as you
bring the love together across the world
yeah yeah yeah in in in what what you
know and however the bandages are mended
to this I'm like you know I'd love to
push all my marbles into that as soon as
possible you know but I I think there
are certain forces that are continuing
to drive whether it be the corporate
greed and power obsession over division
stuff or whether it be the insanity of
Isis and other places of the world that
are going on people that these evil
forces around the world wherever they
are however they're manipulating the
social fabric I do not think those are
my friends
and that's the way that I feel about
things so I don't subscribe to the
everyone love everyone just yet because
there is a bunch of the evil [ __ ]
forces I'm not gonna go hug a guy with
an ak-47 that wants to blow my brains go
stuff well why not mr. lover you know
the peace love and happiness
what the [ __ ] the answer then there
complex problems it's a hard time he's
gonna take offense you don't want to
talk to him and understand where he's
coming from
you're gonna avoid him yeah that's
exactly why that's exactly why we take a
very nuanced and multivariate
perspective across everything all right
now to slam out a couple of these last
thoughts and you tell me if we missed
important things but I just want to make
sure that we addressed this the medium
that everything is being used for
propaganda is mostly digital yes mostly
social mostly through Facebook uh-huh
and so this is the psychometric
profiling of people this is knowing that
we're gonna seem a lot of information
that way these days so yes of course if
I've like knows that if I've liked a
Facebook page like Breitbart or
something that's anti pro-war
anti-muslim or whatever it may be that
that's created some sort of a
psychometric profile of me that is then
if I'm shown an ad that is Pro for me to
feel safe because it's anti-muslim or
aunt their per war or etc then I'm more
likely to react to it with hate I'm more
likely to have that's part of the
propaganda machine quite so simplistic
yes please I would say that so you know
I mean people also don't just absorb
things and parrot them back in an in an
extremely simplistic way but the way
that our propaganda has developed
through digital means has been really
enhanced by the modes of the ability to
essentially carry out corporate
surveillance if you like it's kind of
these platforms are surveilling us at
all times we are being what when we are
buying things with when we are searching
the internet for god knows what and
there are you know all of this says an
awful lot about how we think what we
what we perceive the world to be like
and what we think
of others and and so on and and just
aspects of our personality for example
are really reflected in the kind of
things we say online and and what we
share and what we buy and so on and what
you can do is to shape communications
around that and perhaps you're not going
to turn someone who's a Hillary Clinton
supporter into a a Trump supporter but
that's kind of you know information
might help you to dissuade them from
voting or to channel their vote make
make them perhaps more interested in in
another candidate perhaps or you know it
might even just sow a few seeds of doubt
and I think it's really important also
that it sort of shows you how to how to
evaluate people's triggers in ways that
perhaps we didn't before so there are
things like you know neuroticism or how
open someone is or you know which you
wouldn't have been able to assess in a
pre digital age but know there are tools
that enable you to do that online and
that was how they were able to get such
great accuracy was using these kinds of
sort of not just you know purchasing but
also personality data that was gained
through our through things like Facebook
and so forth so that kind of information
layered on on many other types of
information they can gain such a clear
profile of us that you know even so
things like the colors can be shaped in
ways that might trigger our anxieties a
little bit more deeply than previously
which kind of has sort of an Orwellian
sort of inference really but it's it's
some it's not so unusual in this day and
age it's something that other companies
have done but the
really interesting thing about Cambridge
analytical was the fact that they were
drawing on tools that were coming from
this like central hub that was shared
with a military contractor those
methodologies that they were drawing on
were developed with with DARPA the
military research facilities they were
developed through working with working
on counterterrorism by you know you know
talking to terrorists and so forth it
was all so quickly unpack that last
sentence a little bit more well they
would do research with like we were
saying on target audience analysis they
would do things like interviewing
terrorists and so they would be for
example assessing the kinds of
personalities and so on and traits that
somebody might have as well as the
circumstances they were in during sort
of social science research terrorists
yes they're doing social science
research on the terrorists own
terrorists okay and what do what does
DARPA see the defense contractor what do
they uncover by doing social science
research on the terrorists how
terrorists think waters think they might
respond to why they're doing what
they're doing
they're emotional of psychological
states this is Oliver right yeah okay
this is all very good I'm not saying
nobody should do that okay but so so
we're trying to understand the way
terrorists think to prevent terrorism
fantastic and then how is that this is
people like Nigel Oaks who we just heard
and him okay so SEO group taking
information that the military was I was
that bad so then that was then fed into
this research hub the behavioral
dynamics Institute's which was a central
hub for developing methodology for the
whole of the the SEL group and then
Cambridge analytical who are an
elections company was set up with Anne
to access all of this knowledge and we
don't really know what knowledge they
borrowed from in order to develop the
kinds of method the kind of methodology
that they deployed in our elections so
we don't know if Canberra general could
took information they definitely will
using this hub they were Nigel Oaks told
me that it couldn't have been done
without him without that hub yes okay we
like the methodologies all the BDI we're
at 65 minutes Thank You Ronnie
okay this is absolutely insanely
fascinating and so nuanced I know
nothing about us I'm trying to learn
about it trying to yeah it's a very very
difficult subject because it it it is
literally it's a there's division
there's greed and power
there's xenophobia there's propaganda
deep fake social media cycle metrics I
mean just those things that we just
listed are so insanely emotional and
they're insanely like how do we will
figure out how to work together as a
bunch of advanced chimpanzees on this
rock damn it
very hard very hard I'm grateful to have
people like you that have went deep into
this and are here to teach and enrich
and inspire thank you for coming funny
when I find people who want to learn I
love talking about this I'm very geeky
oh let's at least get a couple of
simulation questions because I wanted it
sounds good yeah let's hear what Emma
has to say about them yeah there will
definitely have to do a little bit of uh
at any rate in but thanks for yeah well
you know I mean we'll have to do a part
two when you're back when you're back in
the area or when we come to the United
Kingdom there will need to be a part two
because there's too much to unpack and
oh yeah this is just the tiny little
scratch on the surface so yeah we're
going to the UK yeah yeah yeah patreon
let's get there all right
ticket sales let's get
all right couple of simulation questions
on the way out first question is do you
think we are alone in the cosmos well I
heard they found water on Mars I think
over something so I don't know who left
probably some amoebas out there some
what they do you would it would what
about rocks orbiting other stars that
are in habitable zone you think some
intelligent species could have evolved
on those possibly I have no idea
I'll be honest I don't stay awake at
night wondering if there's aliens we
have enough of these theories you stay
awake at night talking about propaganda
thinking about propaganda science we
have enough to worry about here
okay how about do you think we're in a
simulation just know if it were a
simulation it's very [ __ ] weird
that's exactly what last question I
think you'll have more of I actually can
give a really good answer to this what
do you thinks the most beautiful thing
in the world
Oh what British where did you see crumbs
crumbs
it's the woodstove root it's the filler
word for oh [ __ ]
is it really cheesy if I say bring him
love do you have someone that you're in
love with right no but in the past yeah
and you thought that that was the most
beautiful thing in the world yeah I love
Chinese food
nothing is more I love the Pink Floyd
Dark Side of the Moon record I love my
disco [ __ ] nothing
what what about love what about the
backseat yeah what about love is most
beautiful for you why why just the the
ability for it to totally and utterly
knock you off this planet and make you
feel like there is nothing that matters
beyond that it's and it feels beautiful
it fills your entire body and yeah there
is nothing else in this world that feels
like it it's incredible yeah that's a
great way to put it yeah everything
stops the other feeling is it goes yes
pretty special it's unique yeah thank
you for that and thank you for all the
so much complexity and depth in ways
I've been researching and teaching us
about thanks so much pleasure to be here
yes everyone for watching thanks for
visiting
Stanford and and being some visiting
scholars I hope come back we hope to
have you back we hope to have you back
in the Bay Area on the show we hope to
come visit in the UK and talk to you
other smart people that are in the UK
researching so many other incredible and
important fields awesome everyone thank
you so much for tuning in if you guys
had a good time give us a comment below
let us know your thoughts
give us some links to some things that
you're reading about this and learning
about it there's so much to learn Emma's
websites also below go check out her
website we'll check out her for their
research and go check out her books as
well check out the fake news inquiry
evidence that there's a lot more these
clips that you heard so I think people
need to hear those yeah because hearing
them definitely gives you a much more
yes deeper understanding read the
analysis as well as three essays I wrote
to company them and that has more
information yep give them a listen give
the glory to the essays let us know your
thoughts like I said below subscribe
during the família also give the content
a share don't just consume this content
we go create what they go write about it
go make videos about other stuff comfort
about to go do your thing do your own
propaganda research become a critic what
are you doing son
Oh propaganda research right now mom so
also join us on patreon help us scale
the effort help us go and make impact on
more people across the world thanks for
joining us thanks Ron I'm
producer/director thanks to our
teammates that are here right now mark
Alfredo much love to you guys as well
thanks everyone for tuning in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]